[Music]
now a big breaking development in the
great state of pennsylvania tonight as
heart surgeon emmy award-winning
television host dr mehmet oz is now
jumping into the republican senate
primary let's take a look
my parents came to america to find a
better life and they did i attended
great universities raised a family and
became a successful surgeon i invented a
heart valve that saves thousands of
lives
then i started a tv show to advocate for
you taking control of your health
and took on the medical establishment to
argue against costly drugs and
skyrocketing medical bills
but kovit has shown us that our system
is broken we lost too many lives too
many jobs and too many opportunities
because washington got it wrong they
took away our freedom without making us
safer and tried to kill our spirit and
our dignity as a heart surgeon i know
how precious life is pennsylvania needs
a conservative who will put america
first one who can reignite our divine
spark bravely fight for freedom and tell
it
like it is that's why i'm running for
senate i'm dr oz and i approve this
message
now dr ross was vowing to run on a
campaign and putting you the american
people first to be a servant of the
people of pennsylvania take on the
washington establishment to protect
fundamental freedoms keeping americans
safe and secure and he says again to
serve the people of pennsylvania here to
talk about his candidacy is dr oz
himself
um there's a lot of similarities before
donald trump ran for office i i've been
friends with him for many years
we had so many conversations
too numerous to count
late into the night and i got to really
know you during covert and you were
calling you know
europe at three in the morning and
updating me on anecdotal information we
had nothing to work with at the time
and
a while back you told me that you were
thinking of running first of all i said
you're nuts it's a it's a horrible world
and i want you to explain in your own
words what you told me and why you're
running
well you did warn me
but today was an exhilarating day and
let me give you a little background
my parents immigrated here legally and
our country provided unparalleled
opportunities that have benefited me and
i feel firmly it is time to repay my
debt america is in crisis that's not
news our values are under attack so i
want to serve america in its time of
need i think i can do that by running
for the u.s senate seat in the state of
pennsylvania now americans and here's
why i see it americans deserve better
solutions doctors are about solutions
but instead people with good ideas are
shamed they're silenced they're bullied
they're canceled you talk about it sean
all the time and in medicine if we
cannot say what we see
people die literally that's why we
always tell the patients the truth
because they'll respect us and we can
deal with realities if we're honest with
each other so let me talk about covert
for a second because as a physician
i really spent a lot of time trying to
understand what went wrong and the
mistakes are emblematic of other issues
that we're struggling with in our great
country remember the phrase two weeks to
flatten the curve right that
metastasized into this incredible
authoritarianism overreaching that did
not necessarily make us safer people
would be with yards big yards told
people with no yards to stay indoors
that's where the virus was remember they
closed the parks they shamed people
about beaches right and now they're
threatening the same overreach with the
armor crime as you were just talking
about
i think those choices should be yours
the american peoples and i have fought
to empower my audience my patients and
now the voters of pennsylvania and i've
taken on big pharma i've gone the battle
with big tech i've gone against aggro
chem companies the big ones right i've
got scars to prove it
and i cannot be botched on cannot be
bought and i'll keep fighting those
battles to empower the folks of
pennsylvania and around the country so
here's what i'm hearing from my patients
from my viewers from people all over the
country there's three basic goals the
first is we need safety right and safety
in our body means high quality health
care that's got to come but on the
streets it means well police you know
there was a college student murdered
this week it broke the all-time record
of 501 murders in philadelphia where i
am right now shameful and we got safety
problems on the borders too which is
basically the narrative is false it's
about cartel's trafficking human beings
that there and is successfully being
done so they keep doing it and they're
bringing opiates along the border with
them that's a hundred thousand people
who've died this year from opiates and
we're not making it hard because we're
letting everything come across the
border the second thing everyone's
telling me is that they want their kids
to thrive they want their kids to do
better than they did i certainly want
that for my children the only way to get
there the path to success is kids is
getting them educated so they you need
choice so you can actually make sure
that you can take kids to where they
need to be you need local rule why
wouldn't you be involved in figuring out
the curriculum of your kids education
and you got to have your values defended
your parents and your in the teachers
values and the kids values need to align
or else the parents win because nobody
loves the kids more than the parents the
third thing everyone's asking me about
are jobs and i thought it's interesting
jobs are about dignity they're about
purpose and they're also about savings
which are being eroded now by inflation
but this is why i'm excited sean the
prognosis is good i think and a good
example of this innovation is when
president trump had operational warp
speed that gave the world the mrna
vaccine right and i don't like mandates
but that was a big advance and america
did that we have that can-do spirit and
america has other great solutions but
we're suffocating them i'm running to
ensure that they see the light of day i
know we can do it and here's my pledge
my promise to everybody i want to be
your public servant and every choice i
make will be serving the citizens of
pennsylvania and the united states and
none of them will serve the special
interests in washington many of whom
i've been to war with for most of my
career let's reinvigorate america and
let's see that divine spark in each
other because it's there
let me ask you this the attacks have
come in already and
allegations you don't even live in
pennsylvania
i'm sure you probably saw that earlier
today
i saw it i grew up just across the
border south of philadelphia i went to
medical school at penn in philadelphia i
went to business school wharton in
philadelphia i met and married my wife
which was the best thing i ever did 36
years ago in philadelphia and i bought
two children or she bore them for me in
philadelphia i became home a year ago it
feels good to be back i love this state
and i will represent it honorably let me
ask you because
um i don't know how much money you make
but syndicated programming that is
successful usually tend to do very well
so you're gonna you're gonna take a big
hit financially so i want to get a
little deeper
because i did say to you this is a blood
sport
um and i warned other people i said are
you prepared for this i talked to
hershel walker for example and
herschel's like i'm ready i can i'm i'm
willing to take whatever it takes and
all of this will come your way in the
days to come
um
what is it specifically i i have a i'm a
registered conservator i'm not a
republican but i mostly end up voting
republican because uh there's we have a
two-party system
i could tell you in a minute what my
political philosophy is but rather than
me tell you mine what is yours
well i'll tell you one thing for sure
any government that's large enough to
give you everything is powerful enough
to take it all away so i don't want that
i want liberty and freedom and that to
me means limited government we can do it
better than folks very far away from us
who don't know our local problems the
more we can be local the more we can
trust the people in our communities the
better off we are i believe in energy
independence that's a big deal here in
pennsylvania but we don't as a nation
want to be begging other countries like
we're starting to do to change what
they're doing with energy because you
know we're in hawk i believe in
capitalism that which means lower taxes
and regulations so people can really
compete and i respect the constitution a
brilliantly written document that i
think should be honored on the bench and
sometimes isn't we have free market
solutions that work and in healthcare
i'll tell you this is my specialty area
and i spent my life studying this we can
protect against pre-existing conditions
and use free market solutions to
healthcare that makes it affordable
accessible for everybody and i got a
little secret for you the worst medicine
is bad medicine the best way to save
money is to give people high quality
care they do better and you don't waste
money
you mentioned immigration earlier and
your parents status where do you stand
on immigration
immigration is a big problem for a
couple reasons for one we're subsidizing
cartels that are involved in human
trafficking i mentioned you're bringing
opiates across the border but lots of
other issues as well i think president
trump was right people should wait on
mexican side of the border if they're
coming across illegally let's deal with
all the issues there and not put law
enforcement in an impossible predicament
where they're forced now that people are
in this country to chase them down when
we know they're not coming back for
their follow-up visits
i say i'm a conservative uh i used to
say i'm a reagan conservative i would
say i'm an america first make america
great again conservative
how would you describe in just a
sentence your political ideology
philosophy you're all running us in a
republican primary how would you sum it
up
i match yours i think this country has
all the building blocks to be
spectacular uh the infighting is uh is
hurting our ability to do what's
possible i know as a physician that when
you come together you save lives i think
we can do that exact same thing in this
nation there's nothing that should hold
us back if we focus on those three goals
i mentioned earlier focus on safe lives
so you feel comfortable make sure your
kids are at least as as able to survive
in the in the future world as you would
have been and then make sure we've got
jobs so people have dignity
you know dr oz um we need better people
to run for office it's become
so vicious hostile look at the way they
treated donald trump for five years um i
wish you luck in this race i've known
you for a long time we've had a lot of
private conversations i know you're
sincere in everything that you're saying
um i i think people the one thing i
really like that you said is you want to
be a public servant of the people and a
lot of people go to washington really
end up serving themselves
i don't suspect that's your motivation
and we look forward to having you back
thanks for being with us